sunrise premier ministre le parlement
rarement été si vide pour adopter en
quelques heures une mesure si colossal
il s'agit de la politique économique
canadienne la plus importante depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale
les députés s'entendent pour débloquer
73 milliards de dollars soit environ le
quart du budget fédéral normale afin
d'aider aux entreprises payer leurs
employés sur le fan unanimes c'est un
contraste avec la séance d'urgence d'il
ya plus de deux semaines
un bras de fer entre les conservateurs
et les libéraux avaient presque fait
dérailler l'adoption de la première
partie du plan daide cette fois ci les
négociations se sont faites en amont
nous avons proposé des amendements et
nous avons assuré que ce projet doit
maintenant c'est mieux que nous avons
les entreprises qui ont perdu 15 % de
leurs revenus en mars devront toutefois
encore attendre avant de recevoir
l'argent mais non c'est deux à cinq
semaines les partis d'opposition qui
sont éclipsés par la crise depuis des
semaines ont profité de leur visite et
ottawa pour soulever leur préoccupation
pour les aînés ont eu rien zéro nada
niet
le npd veut pour sa part que la
prestation d'urgence soit offerte à tous
les canadiens
jusqu'à maintenant près de 6 millions de
personnes et demandé l'aide de 2000 $
par mois
j'existe gouvernement temps laver tous
les critères les conservateurs eurent
réclame le retour en chambre dès que
possible
nous parlons de nombre de députés réduit
dans une façon qui peut respecter les
directions des agences de la santé
mais pour le gouvernement il vaut mieux
attendre que la chambre des communes met
en place son système virtuel d'ici
quelques semaines si on demande aux
canadiens de rester chez eux parce que
c'est la façon de réussir dont on doit
tenir compte de ça aussi
lorsqu'on parle du parlement si les
partis ont présenté un visage uni à la
chambre des communes
en coulisses la situation est différente
il reste moins de dix jours à la
suspension des travaux le 20 avril
approche à grands pas et pour l'instant
aucun consensus ne semble émerger pour
la suite des choses
il siffle vincent foisy radio canada
ottawa